اذا الغرب يندفع لملئ المخزون الاوكراني
من السلاح من الاستعداد في ظل طبعا
الاستعداد لمعركه الشتاء التي قد تكون
حاسمه لاحد الطرفين تسعه اشهر مرات على
الحرب في اوكرانيا وطرفه الصراع بتايا
يستنزفان ما لديهما من ذخيره وعتاد ومعه
تتسارع وتيره الدعم الغربي مسؤولون في
النت وقالوا ان كميه المدفعيه المستخدمه
مذهله ضاربين مثلا بافغانستان التي كانت
فيها قوات الحلف تطلق ما لا يزيد عن 300
قذيفه مدفعيه في اليوم بينما في اوكرانيا
يتم اطلاق الالاف من الطلقات يوميا مع
حاجتكاف المستمره للصواريخ ومضادات الدفاع
الجوي اضاف المسؤولون ان يوم القتال في
اوكرانيا باتى يوازي شهرا او اكثر من
القتال في افغانستان للمقارنه الاوكرانيون
اطلقوا الصيف الماضي في منطقه دومباس ما
بين سته الاف وسبعه الاف تلقى مدفعيه كل
يوم بينما تنتج الولايات المتحده مثلا نحو
15,000 قذيفه شهريه لذلك يسعى الغرب
للعثور على معدات وذخيره من الحقابه
السوفياتيه لتتمكن اوكرانيا من استخدامها
بما في ذلك صواريخ الدفاع الجوي 3 ودبابات
تي 72 اضافه لقذائف المدفعيه من الطراز
السوفيتي اذا في الغرب يحاول اجاده انظمه
بديله حتى لو كانت اقدم لتحل محل تقلص
مخزونات صواريخ الدفاع الجوي الغربيه
باهضه الثمن حتى ان بعض النقاشات تدور حول
استثمارته في المصانع القديمه في جمهوريه
تشيك وسلوفاكيا وبغاريا لاعاده تصنيع
قذائف من العهد السوفيتي وتزويدي اوكرانيا
المحاولات الغربيه دونها عقبات كثيره في
وقت تعمل فيه بعض هذه الدول على تجاوز اي
امر قد يعيق التصدير لاوكرانيا توجد مثلا
مشكله الضوابط القانونيه على الصادرات
والتي تحكم اذا كان يمكن ارسال الاسلحه
والذخيره المباعه سلفا الى دوله اخرى في
حاله حرب هذا من الاسباب التي دفعت
السويسريين بدعوه انها دوله محايده الى
رفض السماح لالمانيا بالتصدير الى
اوكرانيا بعدما ارادت المانيا ارسال ذخيره
مضاده للطائرات بيعت لها وهي من صنع
السويسري ايضا ايطاليا لديها قيود مماثله
على صادرات الاسلحه المصنعه محليا لديها
عقبه اخرى بحسب مسؤول في النيته تحدث
لنيويورك تايمز لان الدول الصغيره
يشمل 20 دوله من اصل 30 في الحلم بينما
الدول العشره المتبقيه هي القادره تقديم
المزيد من فرنسا المانيا ايطاليا وهولندا
اذا في المجمل قدم الدول النت حتى الان
حوالي 40 مليار دولار من الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا وهو ما يقرب من حجم ميزانيه
الدفاع السنويه لفرنسا على جانب الاخر
روسيا تواجه ايضا مشاكل اعاده الامداد وهم
يستخدمون الان عددا اقل من قذائف المدفعيه
رغم وجود الكثير منها لديهم وتحاول موسكو
في مواجهه الدعم الغربي زياده انتاجها
العسكري بينما تفيد التقارير انها تسعى
لشراء صواريخ من كوريا الشماليه والمزيد
من الطائرات المسيره رخيصه الثمن من ايران